[Music]
working for an embassy in a foreign land
may sound pretty alluring but as recent
history has shown us american diplomats
can face extreme danger in their
postings overseas
now the government has responded by
providing an education like no other
before embassy workers head abroad they
head to a special facility in virginia
where the worst that can happen is just
part of the curriculum
christina raffini has the story
keep it straight keep it straight keep
it straight if the goal of diplomacy is
to avoid conflict
let's call this plan b but in an
increasingly unpredictable world
the state department says it wants its
people prepared for anything
from facilitating the expulsion of a
hostile vehicle
to the successful negotiation of
unfamiliar terrain
so it built this the sprawling foreign
affairs security
training center in blackstone virginia
where diplomats are trained how to react
to hostile or dangerous situations
and what to do if the situation goes
from bad
to well i'm hitting fire correction hold
fire
okay
rick gooly is the senior explosives and
countermeasure instructor
and the guy who let me blow up this car
so when you're putting diplomats through
the training
why do you show them this and why do you
want to show them this we want to show
them this to understand that
they need to protect themselves and a
little bit of awareness goes a long way
is this a reality check absolutely the
enhanced training comes after the state
department had its own reality check in
2012
when four americans including ambassador
chris stevens were killed
at the u.s consulate in benghazi libya
benghazi got a lot of focus back here in
washington
as it should of and we did learn lessons
and i think it did demonstrate
we're sending people to some of these
very challenging locations
we owe it to them as u.s citizens to
make sure they're prepared
todd brown is the acting assistant
secretary of the diplomatic security
service
he says the five-day course used to be
reserved for high-risk assignments
now it's standard for anyone going help
each other out
these skills will serve you if it's a
natural disaster someplace or an
incident of crime
a medical emergency i think it just
makes our diplomats better prepared no
matter where they go
this smokehouse simulation teaches them
how to escape a dark burning building
and was added as a direct result of what
happened in libya
trainees also undergo hours of precision
driving
which in my case was
somewhat less than precise did you miss
it i think you might have missed it i
don't know i think i killed it
the final exam is every diplomat's worst
nightmare
an embassy siege the goal is to make it
as realistic as possible so we've got an
embassy that's on fire behind us and
then as they're trying to evacuate
they come across a building full of
casualties where they're asking the
trainees to perform
medical training that they've done
earlier today in addition to having to
get ready to get on the helicopter
and if you can't get on the helicopter
you don't pass the course good job you
did it
excellent is it more dangerous to be a
diplomat now than it was 20 years ago
to say the world is more challenging i
think that's probably a fair statement
the diplomats of today are not
they're not drinking gin and tonics on
the terrace our military uh
colleagues take on significant risks
overseas but so do our diplomats and
and i'm very pleased that we've now have
this facility to train them as they
should be trained and be prepared for
what comes
successful statecraft requires proper
preparation
better to have the training and not need
it then to need it
and not know what to do for cbs this
morning saturday christina rafini
blackstone virginia
great elements there i've done one of
these courses and it gives you an
appreciation not just for the diplomats
but for the people protecting them
who you don't always see in the
spotlight or at the microphone and what
christina was saying there at the end
and what they
the point is that it's so much better to
have this training should you need it
than if you're sitting there and
suddenly don't know when
we've seen the impact of when you don't
have it
and what it can do